it's the mail truck
that is a boat and you know it spongebob
squarepants what is stopping someone
from saying yes to being spongebob if
there's no identification required and
yes he is a square sponge and one could
assume but then why ask him in the first
place
behold the idiot box held by idiots in
an idiot box played for we
the idiots on our own idiot boxes
tv survives this just when i thought
they couldn't get any stupider the most
common tv since youtube comet somehow
makes its way into this episode
don't you two have any pranks well
spongebob is a sponge and patrick is
well patrick so i don't think they do
why you gotta rub that [ __ ] in squidward
[ __ ] squidward
[Music]
imagination
behold the birth of one of history's
most beloved gifs can i have your tv i
was under the impression that squidward
was the type of jerk who would
confidently take a discarded trash tv
without asking permission what is this
character growth i hope they put some
air holes in that box
but they breathe water which surrounds
them
so this is the sort of box tv that even
on wheels creates damaging trenches on
any surface as it scrapes its way to the
living room yet somehow here on the
sandy sea floor it glides as if on ice
where's that remote you mean the remote
we have never seen until this very
moment that remote
i am the lizard why the [ __ ] would a
lizard king scale an icy mountain
i want that story
is so concerned about spongebob and
patrick that he's not opening the box to
make sure they're okay
at what point of imaginary avalanching
and screaming in a cardboard box should
one make sure everything is okay these
are the life-affirming questions
spongebob has been answering poorly
since
not because i already cut off my own
arms
but what is stopping patrick from
cutting off his own legs with whatever
spongebob used to cut off his arms
what they're the ones that imagine this
horribly gruesome situation i'm just
here trying to help
how are you two making that noise better
question how are they shrinking down and
then enlarging each time they exit and
enter the box
how are you doing that first we
establish a base camp at fifteen
thousand feet spongebob would soak
everything up at tv
sense are you trying to say i have no
imagination
no but i am saying you have no pants and
that will always be sinful to me
why haven't i worn this yet well would
you look at that the sombrero hat that
reappears in the camping episode
actually appeared in this episode much
earlier
sent off for surprising me with your
self-referential nonsense
you'll never take me alive coppers
no jolly don't do it episode will never
explain where these new voices are
coming from and so help me if you tell
me to use my
imagination i'll send this show into
oblivion isn't there anything on there
isn't about boxes mtv's the challenge
yes this is okay i mean it's not really
about boxes
if boxes are sentient that means patrick
and spongebob are playing make believe
inside of a living thing's body and
honestly this is all a reminder about
the importance of monitoring your drug
intake before drawing a cartoon
here's what squidward where's the tape
recorder i understand squidward
skepticism but he returns multiple times
to the box even though he can clearly
see there is no tape recorder so unless
he starts looking into spongebob's holes
for a tiny recorder i'd say squidward is
the clear contender for the number one
idiot of this episode
where do you want to go first to the
land of bull where you suddenly sent the
missing tape recorder box and hat box
take me to robot pirate island i wanna
arm wrestle with cowboys
on the moon well wouldn't you need to go
to cowboy moon for that last time i
checked cowboys had been banned from
robot pirate island after the young guns
double feature at the local drive-in got
a little bit out of hand
robot pirate island it is
r to be fair this is way more
entertaining than the last four pirates
of the caribbean films
i finally decided that this box is in
fact made of cardboard when it first
arrived it looked like a normal box but
as the show has progressed it has a
sickly green mold growing on it from the
water
if you're going to create cardboard
boxes underwater make them mold proof
you monsters
we have road we have no road i mean do i
really believe
that if i sit here and pretend to drive
a race car
that i'm suddenly gonna start hearing
noises i have an easier time believing
that than the fact that squidward's
choice of imaginary race car happens to
be the one thing that will line up with
a garbage boat hauling off the
is the box fun i've ever had the most
fun squidward has ever had is being
tossed head over tentacle in a cardboard
box
that is the saddest thing i've ever
heard i just want to point out that
someone baked a pie ate a slice threw it
in the garbage where it made its way
largely
intact to the middle of a dump and we
never know why
people who leave their front doors open
hey our box is gone
yep it's almost like you should have
brought it inside rather than leave it
on the curb
litter bugs
see anything yet patrick i can't see you
can't see
so what all that matters is canon rc
i didn't realize it was happy hopping
[ __ ] day
hang in there buddy the chopper is on
the way visit the chopper
show you with the box who's in the box
it goes manager
section manager head cashier cashier
stalker cleanup crew night cleanup guy
and lastly
boxpoi that's what you are guessing
i mean it's not really about boxes what
is the official language spoken in
australia
touch